he was a talk show Titan and a daytime
TV Game Changer remembering the life of
the one and only Jerry Springer welcome
to Entertainment Tonight coming to you
from cinemacon in Las Vegas Rachel Smith
joining us from New York City you know
Jerry actually hosted the AGT Vegas
stage show here in 2009 and Rach he grew
up not too far from where you are right
now in Queens yeah he did Kev and not to
mention the Jerry Springer Show shot
just 37 miles away from here in
Connecticut E.T was lucky to have many
moments with Jerry over the years yeah
Rachel he was a father an Entertainer
and a TV Legend Jerry Springer Gone Too
Soon at the age of 79.
[Applause]
been a lawyer
a mayor a news anchor and now a talk
show host I think there are a lot of
people rooting for me because if I get
to heaven everyone goes
Jerry passed away last night at his home
in Chicago E.T confirmed the legendary
talk show host was diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer just a few months ago
to get the news Kevin that he had passed
was quite shocking I didn't even know it
was Ill tell you the truth why do you
think Jerry kept it in a tight Circle
that he was sick it's a very very rough
illness so I can only surmise that Jerry
didn't want to be like the topic of one
of his own shows
this morning I talked to two talk show
hosts who knew Jerry well Geraldo Rivera
and Steve Wilkos Steve got his start as
a security guard on the Jerry Springer
Show I went out with them about a month
ago he praised me he hugged me like he
had never done before and he was telling
me he loves me and when I think back now
you know we were reflecting on a lot of
the good times that we had he never told
me he was ill and no no and I think that
night that I saw him was his way of
saying goodbye to me without saying
goodbye Jerry's Blockbuster talk show
ran for nearly 30 years but even in the
final months of his life Jerry still
electrified his fans
[Applause]
this was Jerry's last public appearance
six months ago he was the beetle
eliminated from the mass singer there's
so many serious things going on in the
world to be able to do something that's
just fun and silly and whatever it was
classic Jerry Springer The Humble
lovable ringleader who just wanted to
provide a guilty pleasure escape from
everyday life
that always shows a circus period
stupid but it's fun to do and people
obviously enjoyed it or they wouldn't
have watched and people enjoy being on
he was masterful unflappable with almost
an intellectual approach Jerry's life
was almost as wild as his show I know I
get emotionally becoming
his German Jewish parents escaped the
Nazis Jerry was born in war-torn London
and came with his parents to America in
1949 when he was four do you remember
coming into the harbor in New York yeah
the Statue of Liberty it was freezing
cold and there were 2 000 people on
board
huddling together and no one said a word
Jerry became a lawyer and ran for
congress he lost after a scandal
involving a prostitute but won his race
for mayor when he addressed the
controversy head-on so nine years ago I
spent time with a woman I shouldn't have
and I paid her with a check
I wish I hadn't done that the world and
Legacy of Jerry B you know I'm not
exaggerating when I say the nicest man
in the world
are you kidding me oh
[Music]
we've celebrated with Jerry throughout
the 27 seasons of his iconic talk show
which became so popular in 1998 it
scored more viewers than Oprah but
through it all Springer kept it real
we don't pretend to do anything serious
it has no redeeming social value why
should I have any shame have you seen my
show what does amaze me though is that
people continue to want to share their
most intimate
Secrets or humiliations or whatever with
the world maybe people don't know this
I'm never allowed to know what the
show's about
so they hand me a card but all the card
has on there the names of the guests
because I haven't met them so this way
when I'm surprised I'm really surprised
what was it like to be in competition
with Jerry I know you have this picture
Kevin Oprah I was kind of the mother
hand and Phil Donahue Jerry Montel me
and some of the others I think Jerry
took it to her performance level he was
very visceral yeah very real anybody can
be a talk shower you have to be able to
say you did what come on out we'll be
right back if you can do those three
lines you've got a career
do you ever see yourself retiring no I'm
always afraid not to be
working if I ever had nightmares about
something it's about not having a job
is America's Got Talent during the Run
of his show Jerry did keep busy emceeing
AGT for two seasons but when Springer
ended in 2018 the then 75 year old
showed off his law school education
hosting Judge Jerry which ran for three
seasons next time that happens call him
an Uber it's the first grown-up job I've
had in 30 years
I mean hosting the Jerry Springer Show
is a lot of fun but adults could do it
but his biggest role of all off the set
dad I hope everyone has a moment in life
where
[Music]
at age 62 the proud papa to daughter
Katie who is legally blind joined
Dancing with the Stars season three just
so he could learn to waltz for the
father-daughter dance at her wedding Kim
has agreed to teach me and my fiance to
waltz so that we can keep up with it he
loved his daughter and he he loves his
grandson oh my God I think
you know that injected the new energy
into Jerry I was like Jerry let's do a
show together no I'm retired now I would
love to do that Steve but I'm spending
my time with my family this was the best
moment of anything I've ever done in
Show Business If I never do another
thing in Show Business I'm happy for
this back in 2016 Jerry reflected on his
legacy of course with his signature
humor 25 years from now I think I won't
be talkative
but you can if you just yell loudly
Jerry what do you think I know what I'm
gonna put on my tombstone
I won't be right back
[Music]